la víspera del festival de las Flores es
el momento para vestir esta ciudad de
Centroamérica Lupita Toledo es una de
las floristas más experimentadas por
haber sido la primera ganadora de este
evento que convoca a 2.000 artistas la
emoción de trabajar en las noches es
para que mañana amanezca que se inaugura
el festival
amanezca todo adornado y que todos
nuestros visitantes todas las personas
cuando Despierten verdad lo primero que
van a ver es la belleza de las flores en
las fachadas en las calles según la
asociación de exportadores de Guatemala
las flores aseguran el trabajo
permanente de 15.000 personas al año de
las cuales el 80% son mujeres en esta
edición Lupita escogió rendir un
homenaje a los vestidos icónicos de las
indígenas guatemaltecas realmente yo las
admiro a ellos las mujeres indígenas son
increíblemente creativas
una belleza hacen bellezas con sus manos
son excelentes artesanas para amanecer
Sí ya veo este Qué lindo llegó el día
anhelado por los floristas y con este el
aroma de Las Rosas como abejas con el
polen más de 400.000 turistas se ven
atraídos por los arreglos florales el
tema de esta edición es el de las rosas
perpetuas bueno en la antigua es
conocida románticamente como la ciudad
de Las perpetuas Rosas ha sido mucha
Inspiración de muchos poetas muchos
escritores incluso la historia del
Principito se cree que acá era el
asteroide b612 los artistas compiten por
ganarse el premio del arreglo floral más
original y pues los jueces lo que ven es
un poquito composición originalidad me
encanta por ejemplo esta esta Barbie que
tiene el traje típico de Guatemala y
tiene el café abrazado podría ser que
esto sea muy llamativo para después es a
la hora de calificar la industria de las
Flores deja una ganancia de 120 millones
de dólares un motivo de orgullo para
Guatemala conocido como el país de la
eterna Primavera